[Music]
straight ahead all law and crime daily
one of the charges for the so-called
soho karen is thrown out
the catch is for a case other than the
one she's made headlines for
i was able to obtain a dismissal for mia
poncetto a self-proclaimed rogue militia
member pleads guilty
and turns into a state's witness why
investigators are claiming a victory
in the plot to kidnap the michigan
governor it's the holy grail
working with informants plus as the
trial date for ex-cop derrick chauvin
nears
a judge rules which evidence will come
in and what will be kept out of the
george floyd case
slide on over i know you're a big man
you're gonna have to slide in
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
charges are dropped for the woman dubbed
soho karen in one of her cases
but it's not the one you're probably
thinking of
mia poncetto is accused of attacking the
14 year old son of grammy award-winning
jazz musician kenyon herald at the arlo
hotel in new york in december
no okay then show me this no you get a
life
[Music]
detectives say poncetto wrongly accused
the teen of stealing her iphone
we have what you you see we see two
black people no i'm not letting him walk
away with my phone
records show poncetto had several other
run-ins with the law before
the 22 year old and her mother nicole
poncetto were arrested last february
at the swanky peninsula hotel in los
angeles mia was arrested for public
intoxication
her mother was charged with battery of a
police officer defendant one stated that
she believed she was defending
defendant two resisted arrest from a
beverly hills police officer
and kicked her in the knee kicked the
officer in the knee
the report states there's some redness
on the officer's knee mia poncetto is
also facing dui
and resisting arrest charges in her home
county of ventura
the la judge has agreed to dismiss the
public intoxication charge
well in this case your honor there's no
criminal history outside of a 2020 dui
in california
the declination policy doesn't allow for
any exceptions or factors for
consideration
and i believe the policy requires me to
state that it's in the interest of
justice
as for mother nicole she'll have to
serve 100 hours of community service
over the next year and stay away from
the peninsula hotel before her charges
will be dropped in this case
to the charge on cap one
violation of 243
b battery on a peace officer how you
please
no contest and you understand that a no
contest plea
has the same force and effect as a
guilty plea i understand that
the attorney representing the two women
for this los angeles county case
says her clients are remorseful for the
incident
i will not be talking about any case she
has in new york as you know i'm a
california lawyer i'm not a new york
lawyer and i'm not representing her in
new york cause
that's not my case i can't speak to that
i can tell you that
mia is keeping herself very busy she's
doing well
she's um with her mom and
that's what i know obviously
the entire purpose of everything that
we've done even the gayle king interview
was to express
remorse and to deliver an apology
that is what the purpose of that was so
as you saw nicole was here
and she doesn't want they don't want any
of this publicity they're not seeking it
they're not seeking the fame or anything
and she easily could have stood here
and walked and talked with you folks but
she told me in advance she had an
appointment and she had to leave
joining us now is dina dahl along with
terry austin dina
one charge dismissed but at least three
other cases are still
moving forward could this list of cases
in california affect
mia poncetto in new york you know the
fact is is that what she's charged with
in new york is
rather severe four felonies and they
don't directly
relate but the fact is is that she was
seen you know with her dui
hitting the police officer while he was
arresting her and one of her charges
is attempted assault so it could
possibly come in as kind of like a
prior bad act and showing this but i
think this is also revealing to show
that
that she has a lot more issues than we
originally
had thought the fact that she's even
been caught up now
in criminal activities three different
times i know this is still alleged but
we've all kind of seen on video what
happened
that you know there is a lot more to
this story for this young lady
and and what she has going on in her
life now terry it seems poncetto's
lawyer is working
overtime to apologize for poncero's
actions and say they weren't motivated
by race
do you see these apologies as authentic
strategic or something in between
brian i am definitely not impressed with
the apology i think it's an
understatement to say that she has
anger issues to me all of her actions
come from a place
of privilege like dina said i mean she
was arrested in february 2020
for the intoxication and she actually
hit the police officer in that case
in may of 2020 she was addressed it for
drunk driving and in october again
for suspected drunk driving and we all
know about what happened in new york
where she tried to say that was her cell
phone
and she again attacked so to say that
she
has anger issues i think it all comes
from
privilege and i think that there is some
bias there
yeah definitely an mo that might come
into that new york case based on other
charges
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily a defendant in the alleged
plot to kidnap the michigan governor
flips but first one of the key suspects
in the storming of the u.s capitol
is back in d.c where his case and others
now stand
next
[Music]
domestic terror plots in the united
states seem to be unraveling starting in
michigan
one of six men federally charged with
conspiring to kidnap michigan governor
gretchen whitmer has pled guilty ty
garvin is also agreeing to cooperate
with investigators and become a
government witness
he's scheduled to be sentenced in july
and faces up to life in prison
but prosecutors say they might ask for
no jail time or reduce sentence
garbanz said he was part of a
self-styled militia group called
wolverine watchmen
the group is said to have conducted
field training exercises using tactical
weapons
and unsuccessfully attempted to donate
improvised explosive devices
veteran swat team member lisa lockwood
says garvin told investigators that the
group conducted surveillance on the
governor's vacation
working with informants for three years
working undercover
and having them actually come forward
and
give up everybody that's culpable all
the co-conspirators
and we find out it is truthful through
the evidence that we receive
the phone calls the texts the gps where
they are
and i'm i'm certain the federal
government found that the involvement
with tai
regarding his texts what he did where he
showed up
was his his gps at the shoot house was
he part of it
because he said he never intended on
going through with the plot were they
able to prove that
that he was just a part and parcel to it
he wanted to jump on board with the
other five co-conspirators
and he was less culpable so that was
probably why they made the agreement
because they felt that he was candid
during the interviews and they had
evidence to back it up
back for analysis our attorneys dina
dahl and terry austin dina
what do the defendants have become a
government witness as we've seen there
did you see that coming and what does
that mean for the other defendants
it means for the other defendants it is
going to be much harder for them to
prove their innocence because as we know
the government actually has uncovered
quite a bit of evidence and it's
shocking they planned this for months in
advance
they scoped out her home they did combat
training and when you have somebody who
you know they had an encrypted text
thread but when you have somebody who is
willing to give up
all of those details the case against
the other ones
is going to be a very good case for the
prosecution
now terry with the government having an
informant do you see more defendants
taking plea deals like this one or going
to trial
i think they're going to try to take
plea deals if they can i mean we have at
least six men on the state side and
seven men on the federal side
and i think that it is going to be
difficult for them to go to trial
because
they have all of this information as
dina was saying ty garvin is
talking he's talking about the
conversations the phone calls the
specific
evidence and what really frightens me is
the fact that
he's talking about they discussed a plan
to hold governor whitmer and what they
were going to do with her and
probably the most dangerous part of that
conversation
was the fact that at least one of them
fox is the one that he's talking about
here because when you read the
settlement statement that's what it says
he was obsessed with killing the
governor
so that's frightening and thank god the
plot was thwarted
yeah and these details are going to give
us a glimpse into the intent
of the other defendants one thing that
the prosecutor might have had a hard
time proving
except for this informant thank you both
it's been
three weeks since a mob attacked the u.s
capitol in an effort to stop the results
of the presidential election
from being certified as law and crime's
angeannette levy shows us
one of the highest profile of those
arrested is on the move
the investigation is far from over more
people are being arrested and grand
juries are returning
indictments the self-proclaimed q anon
shaman
jacob chansley has been moved from a
jail in arizona to washington d.c
his lawyer told a st louis tv station
that chansley regrets quote
being duped by trump albert watkins said
something similar to law and crime
there is an alternate universe that
happens to exist in this world
and sometimes some people embrace it and
they move forward with it
and they have an issue chansley has been
indicted by a grand jury in d.c
and faces 28 years in prison if
convicted
he's accused of leaving a threatening
note for vice president mike pence
saying
it's only a matter of time justice is
coming
[Applause]
a grand jury has also indicted three
members of the oath keepers an
anti-government militia group court
records show photos of jessica watkins
donovan crowl
and thomas caldwell at the u.s capitol
they're accused of planning their attack
charged with conspiracy destruction of
government property and obstruction of
an official proceeding
and a new arrest thomas frederick allen
of california
he's also a member of a far-right
militia group the three percenters
allen is accused of stealing papers from
senator mitch mcconnell
and the leader of the proud boys an
all-male neo-fascist group
was arrested two days before the capital
attack accused of vandalizing a black
lives matter banner at a historic black
church
a judge actually banned him from
washington d.c
reuters reports that enrico tario was
quote a prolific informant for local and
federal law enforcement
years ago meanwhile the fbi and etf
are offering a 75 000 reward for
information that leads to the arrest of
a person who left pipe bombs
in the nation's capital one of the heads
of the fbi in washington dc
says that more than 400 suspects have
been identified
through two hundred thousand tips for
law and crime daily i'm angenette levy
thanks for the update anjanet coming up
on law on crime daily an investigation
into accusations of a major retailer
deceiving
consumers plus why a judge had to kick
out a defendant's own mother out of
court
during a sentencing hearing those cases
and more next
[Music]
made in america chief investigative
correspondent brian ross looks into
claims
by major retailers that their products
are made on u.s soil
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
made in america or is it as president
biden has announced steps to push for
made in america products just as
president trump did during his term
there are now questions about whether
consumers are being deceived
is it really made in america are made
overseas
originally when we investigated them in
we found many of walmart's own products
its own brand products uh that were
marketed as made in the usa completely
imported
made in china for example they had
equate makeup sponges marketed made in
the usa
when they were really made in china but
we found
items from clothing to
supplements anything you could think of
we found an example where they
were marketed as made in the usa
when they did not meet that legal
definition
that's coming up this week i'm brian
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network brian thanks for the
update brian
a michigan mother admitted to driving
under the influence when her car struck
an suv
head-on law and crime founder and host
of the a e series court camp
dan abrams has the surprising reaction
to the victim impact statements
we're in the frank murphy hall of
justice in detroit michigan
for the sentencing of 25 year old amanda
casal there's a lot of things that you
can do
and your life doesn't have to be over
because of a poor choice
you just have to accept responsibility
for and find a way
to make something positive out of a very
negative situation
casal has been found guilty of driving
under the influence
causing a head-on collision that killed
31 year-old jerome zerker
and severely injured his fiancee 31 year
old brittany johnson
the couple have five children together
prior to sentencing
the court will hear a powerful impact
statement from the victim's children
read by his sister doreen zerker amanda
look what you did to my life
you ruined everything i had like my
dad's life
amanda seems devastated by doreen's
words
but judge kiana lillard apparently hears
some
snickering from cassal's family sitting
in the gallery
you can go too whoever can sit here at a
tragic moment like this
and laugh and smile when somebody has
lost
a family member this is a court of law
you cannot come down to the frank murphy
hall of justice and act any way you want
to act
that's the defendant's mother donna
because if you don't know how to act you
can go to jail
ma'am you are being taken into custody
for criminal contempt
your disruptive and disrespectful
behavior disrupted today's proceedings
and you ma'am are going to the wayne
county jail for 93 days for direct
criminal contempt anybody else want to
go
try it when we come back
the fast approaching date for the trial
of former minneapolis police officer
derek shovin
what evidence is coming and what's being
kept out after the break
a minneapolis judge overseeing the
george floyd case ruled some prior bad
acts from both
the victim and former officers can't
come in at trial
ex-cop derrick chauvin is scheduled to
stay in trial by himself in march
for second-degree murder and
second-degree manslaughter prosecutors
were seeking to admit evidence of eight
previous incidents
involving chauvin in an attempt to show
he intentionally kneeled
on floyd's neck for more than eight
minutes quote in a manner inconsistent
with training
two of those incidents will come in at
trial and as former prosecutor and law
and crime network host explains
one of those involved a suicidal man in
2015.
there was a case where chauvin was
witnessing other officers
uh actions after they had teased a
gentleman who was in a prone position
but they then put him in a side recovery
uh position and the and those officers
actually got a commendation the
individual was trying to commit suicide
got a commendation that their actions by
putting him on his side
saved his life as opposed to being in
the prone position
and the judge said he is going to allow
that to be admitted
against officer former officer chauvin
if the prosecutors can connect
that sheldon knew that the reason that
that man
lived was because he was put in the
recovery position the judge's ruling
that if prosecutors can make the
connection that show the new
prosecutors can use it to say he had
prior knowledge of the importance
of how to do this correctly
defense attorneys also lost their bid to
admit evidence of floyd's 2007 robbery
conviction
and 2019 minneapolis arrest
keep your hands where i could conceal
them
okay put them up on the dash put them on
the dash
i'm not gonna shoot you put your hands
on the dash
put your hands on the dash the last time
i'm going to tell you that it's simple
he keeps moving his hands around
he won't listen to what i have to say
you're not gonna get beat up or nothing
if you just follow what we're asking you
to do
how does that feel man man i apologize
come on over here i got my paper i got
something in here
i know you're a big man you're gonna
have to slide in
you're gonna slide in he didn't have any
id on him
here to break down the judge's decision
is dina dahl and terry austin dina
badax of george floyd versus that of
derek shoving can you
break down why one may be relevant but
not the other in a murder trial
it's because that the prosecutors need
to approve
intent with murder that chauvin
intentionally did this it wasn't just a
mistake or an
accident so showing that he did similar
things before
or he should have known this type of
force would have led that
goes toward intent but the fact is for
the victim
we don't need to know whether or not the
victim
has done anything other than maybe in
that moment right like if there's some
sort of self-defense or something of
like
that nature but in terms of intent
that's why the prosecution's bad acts
usually can come in
to some extent but we didn't know we
don't need to know the victim's past
just like we don't need to know a
woman's past in a rape trial
it is not relevant to the elements of
the crime
yeah especially if officer chauvin did
not know that information at the time of
the incident
he's not acting based on that 2007 or
2019 occurrence
terry some of the bad acts are coming in
on his art do you agree with the judge's
ruling
and why i do brian i think judge cahill
got it
exactly right he doesn't write an
opinion yet he's going to do that but he
said that under minnesota law evidence
of these prior acts
can be admitted to establish intent or
knowledge or lack of mistake
the evidence that he let in as far as
chauvin was concerned
had to do with lack of mistakes so for
instance
the evidence showed that he understood
the difference between
a deadly chokehold and a non-deadly
chokehold
and the evidence that he kept out like
dina said
was prejudicial had nothing to do as far
as chovin was concerned
and he also didn't let evidence in
as far as chovin was concerned so i
think at the end of the day
his motion was right on well thank you
dina and terry and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you